dans un premier temps on peut souligner
que le premier ministre arménien et
reconnaissants de la contribution russe
dans la stabilisation de la situation
depuis le conflit de ton dernier dans le
haut-karabagh la russie est d'ailleurs
toujours présentes sur place avec des
troupes de maintien de la paix cette
visite est aussi l'occasion de
développer la coopération les relations
bilatérales dans différents domaines
comme la défense l'armée arménienne a
besoin de nouveaux équipements mais
aussi les vaccins en effet l'arménie va
recevoir son premier lot de doses de
spoutnik v nous allons demain recevoir
le premier lot des l'accent russe et
j'espère que cette première partie est
simple partie qui est symbolique sera le
premier pas et après nous allons acheter
beaucoup de vaccins russe comme il est
efficace ce vaccin est pour nous il est
important de faire en sorte que
l'arménie est l'opportunité d'acheter de
se procurer ce vaccin chez nous la
production prend de l'ampleur et il
s'agit maintenant de volume de
production particulièrement important et
je pense que nous devrions pouvoir
résoudre cette question sans que les
citoyens russes en souffrent
l'arménie depuis l'accord de paix du 9
novembre a perdu les trois quarts des
territoires qu'elle contrôlait dans le
haut-karabagh ce qui a provoqué une
grave crise politique elle annonce
d'élections législatives anticipées
mais en dépit de ces soubresauts moscou
continue d'apporter son soutien à erevan